some games use every aspect of their
world systems and mechanics to tell a
clever story the division 2 is not one
of those games as a loot shooter the
division 2 is a hell of a lot of fun the
combat is tight the grind is satisfying
and I love gaining control of the map
I'm about 20 hours in and I have no
intention of stopping soon I also adore
the game's aesthetic and world building
with overgrown streets and abandoned
national monuments you can almost smell
the pavement when a thunderstorm rolls
in during a firefight I prefer the
division ones wintery New York to this
new map but the latter is not lacking in
flavor what's disappointing is that
Ubisoft and massive entertainment don't
capitalize on the potential that world
building brings about that is to say
everything exists on a functional level
but not much more
NPCs don't seem like characters they
exist just to point me to the next fight
settlements are filled with survivors
yet somehow they feel utterly empty as I
explore the map and meet new people and
improve my character the remains of the
nation's capital become a concrete blur
at this point I'm sure many of you are
saying loot shooters do not need a story
and in the past I would have agreed many
people play these games for the
catharsis of the grind and the constant
flow of upgrades those are the main
reasons I played anthem and admittedly
the main reasons I'm enjoying the
division 2 but that kind of thinking can
only hold the genre back over the course
of the first Destiny's lifespan Bungie
gradually emphasized storytelling to
great effect it introduced new villains
flushed out existing characters and
overall made me give a [ __ ] about what I
was doing
destiny 2 has been playing narrative
ketchup for a while now but it is
catching up then there's warframe a game
in which space acrobatics and sci-fi
weapon crafting make way for one of the
biggest narrative twists and not just
loot shooters but modern video games
writ large warframe didn't need to tell
a story as it but it did and it is
monumentally better for it the division
twos narrative flaws are so glaring I
think because the foundation is here for
a great yarn take the Feder outpost for
example it's built on the roof of DC's
titular national theater spilling onto
these structures
baffling and alleyways on a purely
aesthetic level it's clever and I love
improving it over the course of my
playthrough it reinforces my sense of
progress it pushes the idea of
rebuilding the city and by extension the
United States but the majority of the
theaters inhabitants seem to exist only
to serve me the player whether as quest
givers or item vendors they just kind of
stand there
eagerly awaiting my return and the ones
that don't their lifeless husks an early
mission sets the stage for an emotional
wallop as an NPCs 19 year old daughter
has been kidnapped and naturally it's my
job to bring her back I won't spoil what
happens because there's not much to
spoil the aftermath contains all the
emotion of a department store mannequin
the very premise of this game is ripe
for narrative exploration you'll find
yourself fighting through museum
exhibits depicting the Vietnam conflict
and America's expansion West's
opportunities to confront the country's
blood-soaked past and maybe wrest
some sort of meaning from the ruins say
what you will about the first divisions
New York with its cardboard characters
and shotguns spray of a plot but that
game was grim it was oppressive we were
witnessing the collapse of the cultural
center of the world and massive drove
that idea home and as is the case with
many a looot shooter nowadays I'm sure
the developers will put more time and
brainpower into improving the division -
I'm just hoping many of those resources
will go into the narrative department
because more and more the games as
service field is becoming v Prime's onra
to tell a story through players spend
months often years returning to these
worlds they come for the grind and the
reliable thrills and they grow attached
so why not give them a story to talk
about as of now the division - wastes no
time telling me that humanity has lived
on after the collapse it wastes no time
telling me I should care about its
inhabitants but it spends far too little
time actually proving it
you